ecuadorians seem to all want the same
thing as they went to vote for a new
president
crime and poverty poverty all we want to
do is live
but there was no consensus about who
could deliver out of the eight
candidates
Luisa Gonzalez from the left-wing
citizens Revolution party came in first
place but with far fewer votes than
expected the assassination of her arch
rival 12 days ago changed the dynamic of
the election the reason why Luisa
Gonzalez's campaign was the hardest hit
is because Fernando villavicento
represented the most sort of Hardcore
anti-gorithm and he was he had been an
adversary for years and years and years
his assassination immediately sort of
prejudiced Luisa Gonzalez's ticket
but when the counting began 35 year old
Harvard educated businessman Danielle
noboa who went to vote wearing a
bulletproof vest came in second place
I have an immense desire to improve the
situation of the Ecuadorian people today
we all live with a terrible uncertainty
with insecurity and a lack of
opportunities for young people
it was always going to be an
unpredictable
predicted that the son of one of
Ecuador's richest men would sweep into a
runoff presidential election Danielle
noboa is very very new in politics but
he has a lot of money to finance a
social media campaign yet that's not the
only reason so many people voted for him
young people like Luis Garcia say they
want someone who represents them
because he's a young candidate we need
someone young in politics
Luisa Gonzalez described her
disappointing vote as a glass half full
this is the first time in the history of
Ecuador that a woman gets such a high
percentage of votes in the first round
winning the election to be the president
of Ecuador thank you
but you will have her work cut out for
her to win in the runoff in two months a
long time to wait for a country that is
already reeling from uncertainty and
violence
you see a Newman Al Jazeera Quito
foreign